et puis après la question se pose de la
liaison de l'âme et du corps avec des
cartes par exemple qui nous dit
je découpe des cerveaux et je vois que
tout est symétrique dans un cerveau il y
a de l'Aube etc le visage de deux yeux
de narines de oreilles etc petit dans le
cerveau il y a juste un truc là qui est
pas qui est pas double c'est la fameuse
glande pinéale et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'épifice aujourd'hui et il dit c'est là
justement que ce lit la substance
étendue et la substance pensante et on
se dit tiens mais comment l'immatériel
peut-il se trouver dans du matériel et
c'est pas très clair j'ai Descartes il y
a un débat avec Regus ou regius comment
voudra et puis les matérialistes vont
dire bon si un lieu c'est qu'il y a une
matière et que il n'y a que de la
matière donc la même matérielle et là on
passe à autre chose du matérialisme
français qui nous dit elle vécu Diderot
la maîtrise dans le bac etc qui nous
disent ces gens-là il y a une âme et les
matériels et puis après on nous dit mais
les matériels mais peut être aussi
électrique c'est ce que dit Sade dans la
partie philosophique de cette pendant la
partie pornographique et par ensuite on
découvre que je vais vite mais que des
gens comme Elon Musk aujourd'hui disent
bah banco pour une
âme matérielle et électrique et les
susceptible d'être numérisés donc
transmise et donc c'est pourquoi je
parle de vie et de mort c'est à dire de
la préhistoire jusqu'à Elon Musk on voit
qu'elle prend des formes différentes
maintenant on peut être athée et en même
temps exister croire que la existe mais
comme quelque chose de matériel qu'elle
disparaît en même temps que la mort puis
on peut aussi avoir une spiritualité
matérialiste ou athée alors justement
c'est tout ça est très intéressant
moi c'est une question qui me vient à
l'esprit on vous en vous écoutant et
puis en rappelant le titre d'un livre
qui est capital et que je recommande aux
internautes qui qui s'appelle l'âme des
armées de d'Alan Blum est-ce que l'âme
c'est pas quand même une invention
occidentale
je ne crois pas parce que je pense que
dès qu'il y a eu des hommes sur la
planète il y avait une conception de
l'âme je pense que dès qu'on a vu un
mort enfin dès que ces gens ont vu un
mort ils se sont dit mais il ne peut pas
être mort c'est le premier mouvement
qu'on a quand on est en présence d'un
cadavre qui est plus un cadavre aimé
c'est intéressant ce que même dans le
christianisme c'est un débat justement
autour de la résurrection du Christ
puisque j'ai découvert ça récemment
c'est que
pourquoi dans l'Évangile en tout cas le
Christ dit il faut attendre trois jours
parce que les Juifs de l'époque
n'arrive pas à faire la différence entre
un état de coma avancé et un état de
morteline qu'on n'avait pas des
connaissances à l'époque on disait que
au bout de trois jours si si vraiment ça
ça répondait plus c'est que la personne
était morte oui mais c'est vous le
matérialiste dans cette aventure et moi
qui vais faire fonctionner l'allégorie
je pense que la reconstitie de la
reconstruction du Temple en trois jours
c'est ça c'est les gens qui penseraient
que c'est un c'est ce sont les maçons la
chance premier du terme des gens qui
vont refaire un temple en trois jours
bien sûr que non c'est pas pensable mais
l'idée de dire dans le texte de
l'évangile c'est à dire que il y a un
ami plus de 40 ans à le faire
voilà or la reconstitution du temple
elle se fait dans les trois jours qui
rendent possible la résurrection qui
sont consubstantielles à la résurrection
d'où le nécessité de faire une lecture
totalement allégorique et symbolique des
évangiles il n'y a que ça pour moi c'est
à dire pour vous oui oui
après vous pouvez imaginer que une femme
par exemple peut avoir un enfant sans
avoir de rapport sexuel avec un géniteur
des deux éléments constitutifs de la foi
catholique c'est la Virginie Marianne et
la résurrection voilà mais vous pouvez
aussi expliquer que c'est une allégorie
et que dans l'Antiquité il y a plein de
naissance miraculeuses que Platon déjà
exactement de cette manière là six
siècles avant Jésus et donc que c'est
une façon de dire qu'on a épargné par le
mal ou le l'impureté du monde aux
allégorique et si après vous dites non
il va falloir qu'on invente un truc pour
expliquer qu'on peut être
[Musique]
c'est moi qui ai envoyé le message
vous avez un doute parce que c'est ainsi
qu'on fabrique l'âme dans la dénégation
de la mort si on dit quand on est mort
il n'y a plus rien c'est terrible de
vivre avec cette idée si vous dites NON
quelque chose dur quelque chose subsiste
il faut bien que cette chose qui
subsiste vous la poser comme une
immatérialité alors ça c'est très fort
dans un certain nombre de croyances en
particulier en Afrique où il est plus
difficile de savoir où est enterré
l'ancêtre que de connaître les secrets
de défense d'un état
c'est quelque chose aussi pour reprendre
la classification d'Auguste Comte
quelque chose qui selon vous appartient
à l'âge archaïque
j'ai toujours de la peine à juger parce
que on va dire des choses qui me font de
la peine c'est à dire je suis un tenant
de la thèse mythiste comme on dit c'est
à dire de l'existence conceptuelle de
Jésus et pas d'une existence historique
et je sais que ça blesse déjà ça
m'embête parce que je veux dire à un
moment donné j'ai examiné la thèse pas à
Dieu quand on parle de d'un Jésus qui
serait un concept c'est pas c'est pas
faire offense à Dieu après on peut
parler de Dieu autrement mais je pense
que on peut on a construit l'âme et que
partout où il y a eu des humains il y a
eu c'est ce que dit la Rochefoucauld n'a
capacité à regarder le soleil ou la mort
fixement et cette façon qu'on a de dire
dans quelque chose dur de cet être qui
ne peut pas mourir et ce quelque chose
il est invisible puisqu'il est invisible
il est immatériel est-ce que ça c'est
une question enfin vous voulez voir avec
vous c'est est-ce que vous pensez que
il y a une vie après la mort et est-ce
qu'il y a une lame subsiste après la
mort
bien sûr mais
regardez quand qui écrit une critique de
la raison pure qui est terrible quoi
c'est 600 pages il faut quand on a fait
des études de philo il faut avoir lu la
Critique de la raison pure et alors avec
toutes les histoires de quantité qualité
relation modalités avec les histoires
d'antinomie de la raison pure avec moi
c'est un travail quand même très
compliqué à lire infinie il nous dit bon
je postule l'existence de Dieu
l'existence de l'immortète de l'âme et
d'une amie mortelle et l'existence du
libre arbitre on se dit tout ça pour ça
mon postulez on n'a pas besoin de 600
pages pour postuler et c'est quand
lui-même qui ne parvient pas à prouver
il dit je ne parviens pas à prouver je
postule j'en ai besoin d'accord mais on
peut postuler très exactement l'inverse
et c'est Nietzsche par la suite qui lui
va dire moi je postule pas et je vais
détruire tout ça il y a pas de libre
arbitre le dieu n'existe pas et il n'y a
pas d'âme immortelle
alors il y a un certain nombre de
questions de commentaires et
effectivement qui sont sur le chat on va
les partager
moi je voudrais revenir un petit peu sur
des questions un peu plus un peu plus
actuelles et qui relèvent notre pays qui
se passe dans l'actualité je vais
prendre l'actualité parce que je voulais
avoir justement votre votre point de vue
au regard de ce que vous avez écrit la
statue de Saint Michel
qui est
au sable de l'homme qui a été
il n'y a pas de si longtemps les
Sables-d'Olonne mais va être déboulonné
en tous les cas c'est ce qu'a décidé le
Conseil d'État ce qu'a demandé le
Conseil d'État est-ce que vous
réjouissez du zalaïque des juges
administratifs dans cette affaire non
pas du tout pourquoi parce que je suis
tolérant et que je pense que on doit
pouvoir accepter l'existence d'un Saint
Michel dans la rue si on y croit pas on
y croit pas voilà mais et puis c'est pas
très grave je trouve qu'il y a d'autres
d'autres combats à mener et je trouve
que ça procède d'un anti christianisme
civilisationnel donc c'est pas la
vieille laïcité on lutte contre les
curés parce qu'ils ont les pleins
pouvoirs au 19e siècle ils sont dans les
ils sont dans les dans les casernes ils
sont dans les hôpitaux ils sont dans les
écoles là-bas la calotte etc etc c'est
plus le cas du tout donc il y a un
moment donné où il faut arrêter on est
dans une civilisation chrétienne et la
chrétienté moi je pense que la
chrétienté est à défendre et que il y a
pire que la chrétienté c'est quand même
ce que le l'islamo gauchisme nous
présente comme une solution alternative
il y a aucun problème quand il s'agit de
construire des des mosquées pour ces
mêmes gens là et qui sont anticléricaux
de manière assez ciblée et assez précise
et donc je trouve que sur ce sujet on
doit pouvoir accepter qu'il y ait des
statuts de Saint-Michel dans dans une
ville nous sommes parait sidérant comme
l'accepte pas et qu'on se prétend
évidemment tolérante
on revient donc à un animal donc je suis
la meurt avec le corps oui moi je pense
ça oui et quelle certitude vous en avez
je pense que c'est à ceux qui affirme
l'immortalité de l'âme d'en apporter la
preuve ils ont la charge d'apporter je
dis souvent je disais à mes élèves et je
dis que je le disais à mes élèves mais
je veux le redire mais je dis si je dis
que je suis venu vous voir avec une
licorne dans la voiture et je vous
demande expressément de faire la
démonstration que c'est fou je vous
dirai si vous ne parvenez pas à me
prouver que c'est faux c'est donc que
c'est vrai et donc la licorne existe et
je suis venu avec elle non moi je pense
que quand on dit qu'une chose existe et
c'est à soi de d'en faire la
démonstration je vous le redis quand
lui-même n'est pas capable de le montrer
mais d'un autre côté si l'âme n'est pas
immortel ce qu'elle peut exister parce
que c'est pas justement la le propre de
l'immortalité de l'âme de c'est pas le
propre de l'âme d'être immortel ça
dépend je vous dis dans cette histoire
là je montre qu'il y a un moment donné
où elle devient matériel où elle se
matérialise et que on peut voir le
fonctionnement j'ai des mouches noires
peut-être que les internautes sont des
âmes qui reviennent et que l'âme bouge
change je crois qu'avec le
transhumanisme on est aussi en train de
de refabriquer une autre âme que les
gens sont plus aujourd'hui dans le
virtuel que dans le réel et tout le
monde est branché aujourd'hui sur son
téléphone en permanence que les gens des
amoureux à table par exemple devraient
se parler se regarder et ils sont chacun
sur leur téléphone portable en train
d'envoyer des mails ou ils sont ils sont
en réseau c'est à dire ils sont plus
concernés par la virtualité que par la
réalité et d'une certaine manière pour
moi c'est la religion on pense que le
virtuel est plus réel que le réel ce que
Nietzsche appelait un arrière-monde il y
a un arrière-monde dans lequel sont les
âmes des défunts etc regardez le génie
dedans ce qui nous raconte dans la
Divine Comédie ce qui se passe dans les
enfers au Paradis purgatoire etc et je
ne crois pas à ça donc je dis simplement
il y a de la matière quand vous avez un
poisson rouge et que le poisson rouge
meurt et bien il se passe exactement la
même chose pour le poisson rouge que
pour nous et j'aimerais pas pourquoi ce
qui est vivant n'aurait pas une âme
immortelle et pourquoi les poissons
rouges n'auraient pas une âme alors
est-ce que les animaux ont une âme alors
au sens matériel qui est le mien oui
bien sûr c'est à dire que je
toujours ému par le la par le regard
d'un chien par exemple regarde un chat
d'un cheval la mémoire d'un animal ce
que l'animal est capable de concevoir
par exemple mon père me disait mon père
était ouvrier agricole et il me disait
qu'il aime labourrer avec des bœufs avec
des chevaux que les chevaux pouvaient
avoir pour les conserver la mémoire
d'une offense qui leur avait été faite
20 ans en amont et il se souvenait lui
de quelqu'un qui avait été ouvrier avec
lui dans la ferme qui avait maltraité un
cheval qui est revenu voir mon père dans
la ferme et ce cheval s'est mis à se
cabrer quand il a vu voir quand il a vu
cet homme ce qui veut dire que l'animal
avait un conservé une mémoire du passé
si on peut me permettre la redondance
deux que dans le présent il était
capable de présentifier la menace et que
trois il était capable de se dire ce
type qui m'a fait dans le passé mal il
est susceptible de me faire mal puisque
il était capable de se projeter
également dans le futur ça c'est pas le
problème des réflexes c'est des et des
réflexes comme la démontré Pavlov c'est
à dire que c'est quelle est la part de
l'Inst de l'intelligence de la réflexion
il n'y a que de la matière je pense que
nous sommes je crois pas l'inconscient
fraudien moi justement parce qu'il est
immatériel et que vous en prenez encore
affreux oui parce que son inconscient
immatériel c'est pour moi la formulation
positiviste de l'âme au 19e siècle j'ai
lu l'oeuvre complète de Freud pour faire
un livre qui avait fait un peu de bruit
à l'époque et quand vous n'aimez pas
beaucoup
et c'est pas sur le même divan oui mais
je suis sidéré de voir que ne Freud nous
dit exactement la même chose il invente
même le concept de méta psychologique
c'est-à-dire la psychologie au sens grec
du terme le mot c'est psyché c'est l'âme
c'est-à-dire c'est au-delà de l'âme des
Grecs que Freud se pose et il prétend
qu'il est scientifique
justement une question de gipier comment
en tant que matérialiste pouvez-vous
reconduire l'âme et l'idée de substances
ne faut-il pas parler plutôt de
psychisme
je suis pas gêné par ça parce que le
livre a failli s'appeler psyché psyché
il y avait une voix de Ron avait fait un
très gros livre là-dessus enfin bon
personne ne s'en serait souvenu ou très
peu de gens simplement je venais de
faire dans ce dans cette série là de la
brève encyclopédie du monde un livre qui
s'appelle sagesse et qui est une
réhabilitation de la pensée romaine et
je trouvais un peu incohérent de faire
l'éloge de la pensée romaine et de
donner un titre grec à cet ouvrage mais
oui je pense que la psychologie comme
discipline qui s'occupe de l'âme est une
discipline à laquelle je crois je ne
crois pas aux freudisme qui est une
espèce de parapsychologie ou de pensée
magique mais l'idée que la succès l'âme
d'ailleurs en grec l'âme c'est le même
mot que papillon donc il y a cette
espèce de de
légèreté un peu de légèreté au sens
invisibilité sans poids façon éthérée de
ce comporter et je pense que oui elle
monte elle est aspiré je sais que tu as
gardé tout ce qui monte convergent mais
je ne suis pas bien sûr qu'il y ait une
convergence qui qui irait vers Dieu je
pense que je suis c'est un fils de
montant d'une certaine manière c'est à
dire que il y a un cosmos et qu'il y a
une pluralité de cosmos je crois la
pluralité des mondes donc on peut on
peut s'occuper de psychisme et être
matérialiste en même temps je pense que
mon âme va l'âme à laquelle je crois et
matériel qu'il y a des blessures dans
l'âme que nous avons un cerveau que le
lieu de l'âme c'est le cerveau en tant
qu'il est dans un corps c'est pas
seulement dans le cerveau ce dont nous
avons les pianistes ont une mémoire
incroyable enfin les musiciens les gens
qui jouent du violoncelle du violon etc
et je crois que là mais est matérielle
et réductible à de la matière
il y a plein de questions c'est toutes
les prendre mais effectivement je vois
je vois le temps passer le temps au
filet mais c'est passionnant vous
entendre
alors vous dénoncez un certain nombre de
mots le scientisme le biologisme
aujourd'hui le transhumanisme est
également est-ce que justement le fait
croire qu'il y a une âme immatérielle et
immortelle ça garantit pas contre ces
mots
moi je suis vitaliste c'est à dire que
si vous prenez un shaker et que vous
mettez la totalité des atomes qui
constituent un corps vous secouez vous
n'aurez rien de vivant donc il se passe
quelque chose et il y a un débat au 18e
siècle entre les vitalistes plutôt
catholiques et puis les matérialistes il
y a une espèce de réaction les
matérialistes il n'y a de la matière et
les vitalises disent peut-être qu'il y a
de la matière mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe entre la matière qui rend possible
le vivant en est capable de faire plein
de choses mais on n'est pas capable de
faire du vivant pas capable de créer du
vivre et donc le vitaliste que je suis
renvoie volontiers à des expressions
comme elle en vital par exemple chez
Bergson ou volonté de puissance chez
Nietzsche ou vouloir le fameux villeux W
i l l e je vais pas faire le pédant mais
pour éviter de confondre avec la volonté
de choisir j'ai la volonté de prendre ce
livre en main c'est pas c'est pas ça que
dit je peux avoir quand il en parle et
même de Leuze qui est aussi un le
dernier des vitalistes français ou quand
Guilhem il y a une tradition de de
vitaliste et je pense que il y a dans la
vie un vivant qui veut la vie c'est à
dire que j'ai toujours été fasciné par
cette idée que
siècle après vous ouvrez une tombe dans
une pyramide par exemple vous avez une
coupelle dans laquelle vous avez des des
grains de blé ce sont des offrandes qui
ont été faites il y a 47 vous mettez ce
blé dans la terre vous arrosez vous
aurez un épi à la saison suivante il y
avait dans ce il y avait pourtant dans
la matière de cette épice une puissance
vitale qui était là concentrée et qui a
eu besoin de l'eau de la température
arrosage etc et pour que d'un seul coup
ça redevienne un épi je pense qu'il y a
dans tout ce qui est vivant et tout est
vivant sur les planètes le son c'est la
science de la vie des planètes c'est
l'astrophysique aussi bien sur notre
terre la géologie et que il y a du
vivant et que quand le vivant disparaît
c'est la mort ça laisse place à d'autres
vivants et que c'est la chaîne de la vie
que c'est que le vitalisme est une
dynamique vous parlez de génisme d'État
dans votre livre la bioéthique et les
nazis c'est pareil
non je dis pas ça je dis que le génisme
c'est au sens étymologique l'art de bien
conduire la production d'une race des
mots qu'on utilise plus aujourd'hui mais
qu'on utilisait à l'époque où le génisme
existait et il y a un moment donné où
moi par exemple je suis un produit de
l'eugénisme j'ai fait un infarctus quand
j'avais 28 ans 29 ans et bien il y a des
médecins qui disent dans Val sauver en
faire ceci en faire cela de ces une
autre époque je serai mort c'est à dire
j'aurais été inadapté au sens où Darwin
disait que seul subsister les adapter
les mieux adaptés et puis voilà on
disparaît après le génisme c'est la
volonté de fabriquer une race alors à
l'époque on en parlait de l'hygiène
disait il faut pas boire après donc
lutte contre l'alcoolisme qui a été
terrible au 19e siècle l'alcoolisme qui
est encore terrible aujourd'hui mais il
y a par exemple les usages de la drogue
aujourd'hui considérable et des
collégiens qui rentrent à l'école qui
rentrent le matin en cours et qui ont
déjà fumé un pétard en 5e à 8h du matin
enfin dire un collégien faut pas fumer
un pétard avant d'aller en cours surtout
si il a 12 ans
c'est pas être gêniste quand même si
c'est se défend le génisme c'est à dire
qu'il y a un moment donné où il faut
dire aux enfants sachez qu'en faisant
une chose comme ça vous détruisez votre
cerveau que vous avez un capital
cérébral et que ce capital cérébral vous
le mettez en péril il faut faire savoir
que nombre de gens moi j'ai connu hélas
dans mes des gens de tenir leur santé
c'est quand même autre chose que dire il
faut avoir des blond aux yeux bleus ah
oui non mais après tu les handicapés
comme les oui oui non mais c'est pour ça
que vous avez le génisme pour moi c'est
une espèce de d'instrument et après vous
avez un eugénisme nazi et vous avez un
eugénisme libéral le génisme libéral
aujourd'hui qui consiste je vous
rappelle je vous le savez évidemment
mais la fameuse interruption médicale de
grossesse IMG qui n'est pas l'IVG
l'intruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est que pour des raisons
psycho-sociales vous avez la possibilité
d'avorter d'un enfant dans votre ventre
qui aura 8 8 mois et demi par exemple
bah ça c'est de l'eugénisme libéral cet
enfant était un projet il a cessé d'être
un projet on divorce on se sépare on a
une mutation on a une base de son
salaire on perd son emploi je ne sais
quoi ce projet médico-social
et bien psychosocial pardon et vous avez
la possibilité de d'en finir avec un
enfant de 8,9 mois
ça c'est de l'hygiénisme libéral la
possibilité aujourd'hui de fabriquer des
cordes d'enfants avec des petites filles
des garçons et des petites filles des
petites filles avec des garçons toutes
ces opérations sur la sur les
transsexuels avant la majorité légale
c'est un eugénisme libéral un eugénisme
posthume d'une certaine manière si on va
un petit peu plus loin juste sur ces
notions là ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que vous parlez vous prenez
beaucoup sur la Révolution française et
vous établissez enfin en tout cas c'est
ce que ce qu'on se dit en vous lisant et
on vous entendant un espèce de continuum
entre la Révolution française et un
certain nombre de idéologies qui sont
liés jusqu'au transhumanisme qui est la
création à chaque fois d'un homme
nouveau
qui nous dit que avec la foi dans le
Christ on va fabriquer un homme nouveau
qui n'aura plus ni juif ni autre
croyants qu'il n'y aura plus ni esclave
ni maître etc ni homme ni femme mais
c'est en Dieu c'est en la croyant
précisément la croyance en Jésus-Christ
cette idée de il n'y aura plus ni homme
ni femme cette idée de l'homme nouveau
est reprise au 20 au 18e siècle avec les
philosophes une partie d'une grande
partie des philosophes des Lumières avec
une idée chrétienne bien sûr on a
totalement laïcité tout ça et avec cette
idée de régénération c'est terrible ce
mot et je l'ai vu apparaître dans des
textes que j'avais lu sans m'arrêter
là-dessus il reprenne les Jacobins
reprennent l'idée de l'homme nouveau ils
prennent cette idée d'une régénération
s'il y a une régénération c'est qu'on
est dégénéré donc il s'agit de fabriquer
un homme nouveau les Jacobins nous
disent ça va se fabriquer par
l'éducation ça va se fabriquer par la
République et ça va se fabriquer par la
décapitation de tous ceux qui sont des
dégénérés qui sont les dégénérés les AR
les prêtres leurs familles les non
professionnels 200 000 morts en Vendée
20000 morts avec avec la guillotine et
on a des philosophes derrière ça c'est à
dire que vous voyez Diderot vous voyez
mon Pertuis qui sont des gens qui vous
disent très précisément que on y est par
exemple la fameuse imbécile qui vous
disent qu'on pourrait mélanger les races
et les espèces c'est à dire que on
découvre à ce moment-là les sauvages
comme on dit à l'époque de montagne donc
les gens qui viennent des forêts et la
question est qu'est-ce qu'un homme
sauvage qu'est-ce qu'un homme donné
éduqué qu'est-ce qu'un singe qu'est-ce
qu'un qu'un homme digne de ce nom etc
est-ce qu'il pourrait pas un peu copuler
ce serait pas possible et les
philosophes des philosophes condorcés
posent la question dans son dixième
tableau de l'esprit du progrès humain il
nous dit mais on pourrait imaginer des
espèces de croisement entre les hommes
et les singes et on aurait des
domestiques assez facile à utiliser
comme on dit mais c'est ça la
philosophie des Lumières donc il y a un
moment donné où on voit bien que ce
fameux hommes des lumières de de cet
homme nouveau ne fonctionne pas et puis
il y a aussi moi j'adore c'est difficile
de le dire comme ça j'adore mais enfin
Louis XII c'est un petit enfant détruit
par les Jacobins en disant on va le
dresser on va faire une éducation il va
devenir lui aussi un homme nouveau donc
on va lui donner le goût des choses
alors populaire moi je trouve pas que ce
soit forcément un très populaire mais
boire de l'alcool juré être grossier
s'habiller avec des des étoffes un peu
grossières et un personnage qui
s'appelle à l'époque Simon qui maltraite
Louis XVI on sait que cet enfant est tué
et on le tue on le transforme en bête
parce qu'on veut fabriquer un homme
nouveau échec de l'homme nouveau ni la
guillotine ni les guerres de Vendée ni
la destruction de cet enfant de le
dernier roi de France enfin le donne pas
le dernier roi de France mais je veux
dire il a été un roi de France il a
régné le jour où son père meurt il
devient de facto roi donc on tue deux
rois il y a deux Régis ici pendant la
Révolution française et cette idée elle
revient chez Sandrine Rousseau quand
elle non mais vous voyez que vous vous
dites d'abord l'homme nouveau c'est un
ce qu'on trouve chez les fascistes qu'on
trouve chez les bolcheviks qu'on trouve
chez les nazis j'y peux rien c'est un
concept révolutionnaire mais quand vous
allez je ne veux pas dire que ce concept
alors est-ce que c'est un concept
progressiste et bien avec Sandrine
Rousseau on voit bien qu'effectivement
évidemment entendons-nous bien les nazis
ni bolchevique mais je ne sais pas mais
quand elle nous parle d'un homme
déconstruit qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
qui a eu un homme construit qu'il faut
le déconstruire pour le reconstruire
autrement et on voit bien qu'elle
l'aspire aussi à un homme nouveau et on
voit bien que la Genèse aujourd'hui elle
est fabriquée dans l'esprit d'un homme
nouveau il faut être écho responsable il
faut célébrer l'hybridité il faut
célébrer le souci de la planète et puis
on a pas besoin forcément de savoir lire
écrire qu'on dépensé ça c'est fasciste
c'est réactionnaires donc cette espèce
de vieux concept d'homme nouveau qui
évidemment supposait la transcendance
chrétienne chez Saint Paul est un
concept repris et laïcisé par la
Révolution française mais le pire de la
Révolution française c'est-à-dire déjà
cobains et par le jacobinisme mais on
sait que le jacobinisme va fasciner le
fascisme il a fasciné le bolchevisme on
sait que Lénine était un fanatique de
Mara et de et de Robespierre et nous
avons aujourd'hui je ne vous apprends
rien des fanatiques de Robespierre dans
la classe politique française est-ce que
le est-ce qu'on retrouve ça dans le
walking oui bien sûr c'est complètement
ça c'est à dire que le walkis ne va pas
sans un talent pour un certain talent
pour la destruction pour la
déconstruction et la déconstruction
intellectuelle ça va bien quand c'est de
Leuze Foucault guatari pourquoi pas vous
en prenez un peu oui ils sont terribles
quand même
de votre point de vue Foucault et de
gauche
fouille il a il a tout été si on fait un
peu de biographie les gaullistes sous de
Gaulle il est maoïste en 68 il est
structuraliste à un moment donné
c'est-à-dire postmarksistes il est
gauchiste parce que c'est à la mode et
puis sur la fin il était en train de
virer libéral avec François eval des
quelques autres c'était cet homme a été
un grand opportuniste on n'est pas par
hasard d'ailleurs professeur au Collège
de France sans ça et et il a été la
chance
je vais pas parler de moi dans cette
configuration je dis simplement que
quand on occupe des lieux de pouvoir ce
qui était aussi le cas de Bourdieu il
faut s'en occuper quoi ça ne vous arrive
pas comme ça par exemple Foucault est
quelqu'un qui écrit un livre qui
s'appelle surveiller punir sur les
prisons qui fascinent Robert Badinter on
a l'impression que quand Badinter reçoit
la chancellerie et Michel Foucault il
rencontre un dieu vivant et Michel
Foucault n'a jamais mis les pieds dans
une prison
voilà je dis simplement que voilà des
gens qui travaillent sur des archives
qui disent la prison mais qui n'ont
jamais vu une prison de l'Intérieur moi
j'ai vu plus de prisonniers que lui
parce qu'il m'est arrivé de faire des
conférences dans des prisons et on se
dit mais est-ce que on a vraiment besoin
de philosophes qui ont plus le souci de
l'archive qui dit le monde que le monde
lui-même qui plus est quand il s'agit de
déterminer une politique pénale qui fait
encore la loi aujourd'hui alors le temps
fil Michel Onfray va falloir que on
abrège et faudra que vous reveniez qu'on
en discute c'est ce qu'on s'était dit la
fois dernière donc chose promise chose
due vous êtes là il y a un
concept que vous vous forgez dans ce
livre concept léger mais qui est le
puritanisme californ enfin
l'homme puritano californien
versus le Greco le greco-roma
et Julien et vous avez
vous dites la Californie aujourd'hui
c'est c'est géniaux place to be espèce
de de d'environnement en tous les cas
qui qui est le centre du monde pourtant
on voit quand même d'un point de vue
géopolitique que l'histoire se fait un
peu ailleurs quand même aujourd'hui elle
se fait le retour de l'histoire le
retour de la géographie comme disait
Robert Caplan en Ukraine peut-être en
Chine et à Taïwan demain
ça je dirais que ce sont des épis
phénomènes franchement et que l'Ukraine
soit russe ou ukrainienne moi j'aspire
est-ce qu'elle soit
ukrainienne puisque je suis
souverainiste donc je suis pour tous les
pays et je le suis aussi pour Taïwan
donc mais je pense que c'est au delà
l'histoire là je parle de Milan je pense
qu'il s'agit de changement de
civilisation il s'agit pas de résoudre
un conflit dans les un conflits
classiques je dirais de de récupération
de territoire ou d'envahissements ou
d'impérialisme il s'agit d'impérialisme
chez les Russes il s'agit d'un
impérialisme monsieur des Chinois
également je suis pas impérialiste je
suis nationaliste je défends les nations
contre les empires et je ne crois pas la
jurisprudence de Mitterrand le
nationalisme c'est la guerre je pense
que c'est l'impérialisme qui est la
guerre que la guerre 14-18 ne s'est pas
faite entre des nations mais entre des
empires ça il faut déconstruire un peu
le la lecture de l'histoire je dis
qu'effectivement il y a des tuilages il
y a eu des Grecs puis il y a eu des
Romains et ça donnait le Grégor romain
et puis il y a eu des Juifs il y a eu
des chrétiens ça a donné le
judo-chrétien et puis le Grégor romain
et le gigiogue et le judo-chrétien ont
donné effectivement l'utilisation qui
était aujourd'hui un mélange de
puritanisme et des États-Unis mais de
côte ouest des États-Unis jadis c'était
la loi américaine elle était faite par
Washington par par exemple
progressiste
de libéralisme en tout cas de
matérialisme économique plus à l'extrême
oui encore que est-ce que c'est vraiment
oui c'est le libéralisme ce sont des
gens qui sont des libertariens donc le
libertarien dit pas d'Etat pas de
contrainte laissez-moi faire tout
s'achète tout se vend et de fait je
dirais le pôle s'est déplacé nous avons
eu une France dominante dans une Europe
je rappelle que vous savez mais que la
langue de la diplomatie ça a été
longtemps la France le français donc on
y est plus c'est l'Anglais maintenant et
que le déplacement c'est fait
c'est-à-dire la puissance n'est plus en
Europe aujourd'hui sûrement pas en
France sur le chef d'État qu'on a mais
ça s'est fait aux États-Unis et sur
cette côte ouest où les gafams font la
loi et je pense que on n'échappera pas
ça parce que les que ce soit l'Ukraine
ou Taïwan les gars femme n'en ont rien à
faire j'ai une dernière toute dernière
question à vous poser est-ce que le
Normand que vous êtes à l'histoire d'une
âme d'une autre grande normande
bien sûr mais qu'est-ce que vous en avez
gardé
alors écoutez c'est tout le problème
avec les gens qui ont la foi c'est à
dire qu'ils parlent d'un monde auquel je
ne comprends rien c'est à dire que c'est
par moi c'est un roman quoi c'est une
fiction c'est une invention alors c'est
très beau c'est très lyrique limite naïf
il y a quelque chose de naïf chez la
petite sur Thérèse mais des dernières
questions quel est le livre que vous
lisez en ce moment agent lis plusieurs
je suis toujours sur plusieurs ouvrages
en même temps qu'est-ce que j'ai dans ma
valise là tout de suite je
le premier qui vous vient à l'esprit
c'est un livre sur je s'appelle Jésus
a-t-il existé ce sont des mythistes de
de début du 20e siècle ça sera au moins
ça dans Ça c'est une vraie question
qu'il faudrait qu'on aime à un moment au
jour au moment de Pâques
et votre prochain livre
il y en a plusieurs ils sont déjà faits
ils sont déjà écrits alors il y en a qui
s'appelleraient le fétiche et la
marchandise qui est une lecture une
relecture de Huxley et du meilleur des
mondes il y en a d'autres qui s'appelle
patience dans les ruines qui est un
éloge de la messe en latin et que
j'avais écrit en allant à l'abbaye de la
grasse je faisais partie de ceux qui
sont allés à l'habit de la grâce puis
quand j'ai vu que c'était
Saint-Germain-des-Prés qui s'y retrouver
je me suis dit je retire mon texte je
veux pas côtoyer un certain nombre de
gens qui se trouvent dans ce volume et
donc j'ai lu à l'abbaye puis après en
rentrant chez moi les heures j'ai lu les
textes les sermons sur la décadence de
d'Augustin et j'ai fait un livre sur ce
sujet là ça ce sont les deux livres
qu'on lira avec profit et puis vous
viendrez nous en reparler oui je prépare
aussi un Jésus c'est pourquoi j'ai ce
fameux Jésus dans ma dans mes valises
avec d'autres lignes sur cette idée que
Jésus n'a pas historiquement existé mais
qu'il était un concept alors ça c'est
effectivement ça mérite d'être lui parce
que il y a quand même un certain nombre
de documents et donc ça c'est une
prochaine discussion anima c'est chez
Albin Michel c'est votre dernier livre
pas le seul bien loin s'en fout et bien
sûr c'est à dire et c'est extrêmement
intéressant comme souvent extrêmement
passionnant et puis je rappelle
également la dernière livraison de Front
populaire et qui est consacrée à la
tyrannie des minorités
[Musique]